welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka cobb vanth banth
refrigeration
in this video we're breaking down our
100 favorite easter eggs in season two
of the mandalorian
right from the beginning the season is
filled to the brim with cool little
details
and early on grogu and mando walk past a
wall filled with graffiti
this displays c-3po as well as some snow
troopers
a couple of jawas can be seen at the
bottom right and a rebellion symbol
along with some text that translates to
alderaan this lets us know early on
there's going to be a whole host of
easter eggs to be found
and it's not too long before we see some
gamoreans in a fighting arena
battling it out with stun axes shortly
after mano makes his way to tatooine
and one of the first things pelimodo
says is so he likes droids now
this is a reference to the first season
in which the character
famously hated them and distrusted all
of them that
though i like a good pleasure bot now in
episode 1 he shot ig 11
before he could make a move on grogu but
by the end of the season he'd come to
find a new appreciation for the droid
and even removed his helmet in front of
it which in turn allowed it to save his
life
i think that the engine pelly stands in
front of might also be sibulber's
podracer one completely dismantled
and in episode two we see this is used
to cook some crate dragon steak
that reminds me i must remember to buy
some steak and eggs for tea
now the pit droids return from the
phantom menace however we
also see quite a big character back with
the arrival of r5
who you may remember from a new hope r5
was actually bought by luke instead of
r2
but after his motivator bust he was
swapped for everyone's favorite
astromech droid
i love how you can actually see oil
leaking out of one of the flaps on his
top
and this is the same one that burst all
the way back in episode 4
and changed the fate of the galaxy mano
heads to mos palgo
and he rides on top of what looks like
anakin's swoop bike from the attack of
the clones
later in the episode cobb van rides on
top of his pod racer engine
so we have this nice moment in which we
can see the vehicles that the character
had on tatooine from the prequels
a cob actually comes from the expanded
universe books aftermath
and similar to what we see in the show
he wears boba fett's armor
it's pretty ill-fitting and suggests to
us that it may look better on someone
else
which we'll get into later in the video
now the settlement is attacked by a
crate dragon
and this sets up a jaws motif for the
entry later on we see a tuscan raider
drop an exploding canister
and this is similar to the scene in jaws
in which the tanks are pointed out as
being very dangerous
cobb goes into his backstory and we also
see him pick up a case full of crystals
in order to pay the jaws later
this not only featured in battlefront 2
but the prop date all the way back to
the empire strikes back
where is actually an ice cream maker
that has now gone on to become a
container in the star wars universe
we see mando and cobb travel out to meet
some tuscan raiders
and they join their site the raiders are
later seen riding in single file
and as we learned in a new hope the
creatures always do this to hide their
numbers
now they team up with the villagers to
take down the krait dragon amanda
actually knocks vance jetpack to send
him out of the area
similar to what han did to bobber in
return of the jedi after being swallowed
by the dragon
mano goes flying out of its mouth
surviving the acid its spews and also
potentially hinting to us how boba fett
managed to survive the sarlacc
now we see bubba at the end of the
episode and by the end of the season we
haven't confirmed that he was the one
who saved fenic
all the way back in chapter five skip to
episode two
and though this is pretty fillery
there's still some cooler easter eggs in
it
after being attacked by bounty hunters
amanda returns to the cantina from the
first season
and a new hope as mentioned in our
earlier videos this place used to have a
strict no droids policy
but looks like things have changed as
they're now more than happy to have them
working behind the bar
this robot is actually k99 who you may
recognize from jabba's palace
but after things went to hell he
obviously had to look for new employment
mano meets pelly who's playing sabacc
against
a funny looking ant-man creature now
this is actually a nice little easter
egg added by this entry's director
peyton reed
who also directed the mcu ant-man movies
sabacc is a card game that's laced
throughout the star wars universe
and it's what han solo actually played
against lando in order to win the
millennium falcon
now pele gives amanda a job to transport
frog lady
and her delicious delicious chase
tasting ex
during this journey two x-wing pilots
appear to question him
and one of these is dave fellaini aka
the creator of the clone wars
falloni actually directed the jedi
episode featuring ahsoka
so it's nice that he makes a little
cameo here too
after trying to outrun them mando crash
lands on an ice planet
which is where frog lady uses zero to
communicate with mando
this guy once again is voiced by richard
iote who
you may know from goth morengi's dark
place frog lady goes to a nearby cave to
bathe
and groga amando end up going in after
her this egg scene is very reminiscent
of the one from alien
and similar to that we watch all horror
unfolding after the eggs hatch
these are quickness from rebels but
whereas they were immune to blaster
boats
here they can be taken out manto gets
some help from the x-wing pilots
and on the hull we can see little tie
fighter symbols showing how many each
pilot is taken out
mando makes his way to trask and then
crash lands on the planet
this episode was directed by bryce
dallas howard and the crash landing is
actually a reference to her father's
work apollo 13
in which a similar scene happened we've
placed these moments on top of each
other on screen right now
so you can see all the similarities
shout out to lucia briones for putting
this together
and it really shows the attention to
detail that bryce put into this entry
the ship sets on fire because of the
damage to it and
this is meant to also mirror the crash
landing at the start of revenge of the
sith
mando is fished out by a crane which
looks like it's built using the legs of
an 8080
8080s themselves were designed to look
like cranes
so this is a nice little easter egg in
which everything's come back around
mano comes face to face with a mon
calamari mechanic
and we also see on the planet that there
are several quarren
the quaran try and ambush mando and
double cross him
whereas the mon calamari simply want to
help the character
though the two species are actually from
the planet deck they have
long chosen opposing sides throughout
pretty much all of the conflicts we know
about
the quaran sided with the separatists
and later the empire
whereas the mon calamari were on the
side of the rebels in republic
so one helping mano whilst the other
betrays him it's actually
deeply rooted in star wars mythos hey
not bad
amanda goes to a diner for some help and
a squid-like creature attaches itself to
groggy's face
which could be building on the alien
motif from the prior entry
it's not too long before we meet bo
kitan and the way she reaches in to
pulmando out
mirrors how a member of the death watch
pulled him out of his hiding place as a
child
beau is played by katie sakhoff who also
voiced her in the animated shows
and she's joined by sasha banks who
hopefully gets more screen time in
season 3.
together they decide to attack an
imperial freighter and when doing so we
can hear the alarms sound that was also
present on the death star
they take over the ship and beau points
mando in the direction of ahsoka
which still gives me goosebumps this
takes mando to episode 4
namely navarro where we join cara dune
going through the covert which is the
base that the mandalorians used in the
last season
above the armorers door used to hang a
mythosaur skull symbol
but we can see from the imprint that
it's now missing
cara takes down the aqualish inside and
you may recognize these as being from
the same species as panda baba
navarro has gone through a big makeover
since muff gideon left
and we see the marketplace is teeming
with people which is a complete opposite
to how it was in season one
you can also spot a statue dedicated to
ig-11
who was of course instrumental in
freeing the area from the grip of the
empire
the bounty hunter bar where mando met
grief in season 1
is now also a school and we can see a
kid with the same haircut that rey had
in the last jedi
grogu steals some macarons is it
macarons
i don't know and they're the same color
as bantam milk
meaning that they were likely made from
them mano meets mitral again from the
first season
and he says he can't see out of his left
eye if you can't see mine back to return
of the jedi you may remember that when
he was freed
han solo was blind for a bit so this is
a nice little carryover of that motif
they go to the reactor which just so
happens to also look like the tractor
beam control that obi-wan went to in a
new hope
similar to that there's no railing and
family guy of course
made fun of this in their star wars
trilogy parody
mano and co discover a cloning lab and
we can see a patch on the scientists arm
that is the same as the camino clona
symbols
we discover what looks like it could
either be a clone of palpatine or snoke
and then learn that the empire won grogu
for his midichlorians so that they can
put them into the body
the show has slowly been bridging the
gap between the original and sequel
trilogy
i think this scene is very important in
explaining why certain things happened
in the rise of skywalker
originally cloned in star wars were not
meant to be force sensitive
however they have found a way to explain
why pulps came back in rise
and was also able to be a sith lord now
the jeans guy has since been removed
but shout out to my ogs who spotted him
lurking in the background day one
the force will be with you always
speaking of my og's though
did you know that you'll get 50 years
good luck if you like this video and
also subscribe to the channel
you didn't well you may want to as we're
giving away three free copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to people
are part of our following
but i'll talk about that more as we wrap
up the video okay because
you well you want these easter eggs
don't you so back to them
we get an amazing chase scene in which
cora drives her
grief and mithral over the edge of the
base in a troop transport
you slow the scene down and see their
reactions you'll notice that kara is
actually smiling whilst doing this
whilst the others look absolutely
terrified you watch as they're chased by
tie fighters
which also have the same landing
apparatus used by moff gideons
showing that this is now the
standardized designed for them
we get a return of the x-wing pilot
carson tiva and he asks cara if she lost
anyone on alderaan like like dude the
the entire planet was blown up but what
what do you think what a stupid quest
anyway he says that something is going
on in the outer rim
and as we know from the sequel trilogy
both the first order and palpatine's
forces worked away there in order to
rebuild their power
cut them off gideon's ship which comes
in at a similar angle to how the star
destroyer did
during the start of a new hope this
symbolized the empire's reach and
superiority throughout space
and it's been echoed here for that exact
specific reason
jump to episode 5 directed by dave
filoni and we open with ahsoka
tearing up the forces of the magistrate
the last time we saw her on rebels
she was wearing a white cloak however
it's darker here and similar to luke's
in return of the jedi
it perhaps shows that she's moved away
from the idealism that she used to have
the magistrate is played by diana lee
aino santo
who is also the god daughter of bruce
lee michael bean pops up in the episode
and you may remember him from both the
terminator and aliens
those aren't the only references to
films either and several shots in the
entry mirror the japanese classic
yojimbo
in fact this entire episode pretty much
shares the same plot as that film
and it's clear that filoni is riffing on
it in a number of ways
after the intro mando lands on the
planet and goes through the city which
is where we see
torchy devices that look very similar to
what thrawn used on hera and rebels
we learned that thrawn and the
magistrate are connected so it may be
possible that he actually gave her these
mano meets the magistrate outside her
palace which looks very similar to
jabba's
hinting that she too may be a gangster
that rules over the area like he did
mana goes out looking for ahsoka and in
the trees we can see an owl who may or
may not be morai
aka her companion when discussing grogu
ahsoka mentions yoda
and how she doesn't want to train him as
she's seen what's happened to the best
of the jedi
in the clone wars ahsoka was actually
anakin's padawan
so the character has witnessed firsthand
what can happen when a jedi loses
someone that they're close to
ahsoka says she sent as much fear in him
which is also what yoda said to a young
anakin at the jedi temple
in the phantom menace now sokka finds
out where thrawn is
and from the recently announced ahsoka
disney plus series
it's clear she's going to be heading out
after him jump to episode 6
amanda arrives on tithe on to place
groga on the seeing stone
we actually saw luke using one of these
in the last jedi to reach out
so it could be possible that these are a
staple of the jedi religion
the blue writing on it that appears is
also similar to what was placed on the
jedi temple spheres in fallen order
and this ties everything together with
the greater law we can also see that
blue butterflies are floating around the
area
and typically in star wars law these are
actually used to send messages
so grogu sending a message to the jedi
here is also
laced in the environment slave one
arrives
and and who else yeah be honest
absolutely fanboyed out over this moment
fett says he's a simple man making his
way through the galaxy
which his father also said to obi-wan
when they first met an attack of the
clones
stormtroopers arrive and you might
recognize these ships from the start of
the force
awakens as they were used to transport
troops as well
stuff goes down and i loved actually
seeing phet be a badass for once instead
of someone who got taken out by a blind
guy
and kind of missed a maguda's way
through everything mana returns to car
to find the location of mayfield
and the lineup of prisoners here
actually looks very similar to the ones
that try to take grogu
all the way back at the start of episode
2. cut to episode 7 and we pick up on a
junkyard planet
full of the cranes from earlier as well
as wrecked tie fighters
x-wing engines and an atsd head cora
escorts mayfield away
and we see bubba sporting his brand new
armor though the dent in the helmet
still remains
upon taking off we can see that the hull
of the ship actually rotates
and this is because slave 1 spins on its
axis in order to fly correctly
now in this episode they attempt to get
the imperial protocols in order to
locate maf gideon
and we watch as the pair disguise
themselves as imperial transport
troopers
throughout the saga we watched the
design of the helmets change
and in the prequel trilogy the clone
troopers looked very similar to django's
by the original trilogy we saw as a
stormtrooper helmet change for the more
famous design
and in the sequel one there was sort of
just a slit to the eyes
here we can see that appearing too
showing how the design has shifted
throughout the saga
we discover that your face has to be
scanned in order to get the information
and that this could cause a lot of
issues with the group cara is of course
an ex-rebel with the face that's still
on show
and boba has well the same faces not
only django
but every other clone trooper that's
ever existed
so yeah it's not gonna fly there's also
mention of the isb
which are basically the internal affairs
of the empire
fenix says that she's wanted by them and
in the recently released bad batch
trailer
we see why she might indeed be on the
run mando and mayfield managed to make
it to the imperial base
and we also see some short troopers who
you may recognize from rogue one
inside the base mando is confronted by
valon hesse
played by richard brake and though
mayfeld manages to keep him under cover
they have to hang around in order to
keep up the facade however
may fall does try and come up with the
excuse of having to fill in some tps
reports
which is a nod to the pointless report
in office space
the trio sit down in an almost
inglorious bastards like exchange
that sees operation cinder being brought
up cinder was actually a big plot point
in battlefront 2
and it involved the empire firing on its
own planets and people
in order to destroy as much as they
could after the fall of the emperor
mayfield loses it and shoots hess first
similar to how han shot greedo first
during a new hope
and yeah i'll never accept anything else
the pair then escape in slave one
and blow the base by shooting the
redonium however they're pursued by
ties and boba ends up dropping a seismic
charge
you might remember that django used this
on obi-wan an attack of the clones
and it's an awesome way to get rid of
both the ties the episode ends with
mando sending a message to moff gideon
and this actually plays upon the
antagonist's speech from the first
season
however where is the moth called grogu
it mano calls him he
so he can actually see that he has a
personal connection to him
instead of just viewing him like an
object now episode a
is arguably the best star wars we've had
in the past 10 years
and it follows mando as he leads a
charge to get grogu back
we joined slave 1 using ion cannons to
disable the lambda shuttle that dr
pershing is on
one of the pilots is the same actor that
played nathaniel malik in agents of
shield
and shouted everyone who followed me on
those breakdowns mano then returns to
bowgetan
and koskarevs when slave 1 lands we can
catch bo's gauntlet ship
which you may remember from the animated
series that she featured in
they meet the pair both of whom throw
some insults bobber's way
and one of these includes koskas saying
that he'll end up talking from a back to
tank
you may remember these from the empire
strikes back as they're typically used
to heal people
so this this is like the star wars
equivalent of saying you'll be talking
trash from a hospital bed
now they eventually join together and
storm them off ship during which
mando comes across 3b6 or a7
you may remember from a new hope in the
sound crawler mano defeats them off
and we discover that he's already
perfected the technique on taking the
blood of grogu and placing it into a
clone
thus how palpatine returned has been set
up by the series
that's not the only connection to the
main saga either and luke skywalker of
course returns wearing the same clothes
and cloak that we saw him donning in
return of the jedi
his arrival echoes the ending of rogue
one in several ways
and when he first appears we can see him
coming through a smoke-filled doorway
darth vader of course did this at the
end of the movie and
similar to luke he completely wrecked
shop now what i loved about this scene
is that vader force choked one of the
rebel forces and we also see luke doing
something similar to a dog trooper
this makes it an amazing father and son
moment and it's probably one of my
favorite star wars easter eggs ever
again it's like poetry so if they rhyme
every stanza kind of rhymes with the
last one
now what makes his arrival so emotional
is not only luke's theme that is used in
the music
but also the return of r2d2 and how the
scene mirrors the father and son moment
shared by luke and his dad
you may remember at the end of return of
the jedi that luke removed vader's
helmet so that he could properly look on
his son
that moment is mirrored here with mano
taking his off so he can also
say goodbye to his boy i promise i
wouldn't cry now we watch as
luke carries him over his shoulder and
this of course was also done by mando
throughout the season
he stares like a sad dad watching his
son go off to college
and it's a heartbreaking moment anyway i
i think luke's very lucky that baba
wasn't there for this
as it would have been quite awkward now
we cut to the post credits scene
and we see the twin sons of tatooine and
return to jabba's palace
bib fortuna who was jabba's right hand
in return of the jedi has now taken over
but it's not too long before baba ousts
him we end with the book of mando closed
and start a new chapter called the book
of boba fett which is due to air in
december 2021
anyway that wraps up the video and don't
forget that on the 30th of december
we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
favorite easter egg if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
finale which is going to be linked on
screen right now
we go over the entire thing from top to
bottom so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
may the force be with you i'll see you
next time take care
peace